all right let's go to the questions from
the internets this is for you Dana on
your radio show you liken negotiating
with health reform advocates oh yes I
saw this too negotiating with terrorists
and I didn't bring it up on this show
for because you know what I don't think
you really think that healthcare reform
advocates are terrorism no and that's
not what I said I was talking about when
you're if you're holding something like
ransom if you're like in if you are do
the tactics that you do you're holding
specific things ransom in order to get
something else I mean come on aren't
conservatives always chide it as if you
guys don't have a sense of humor or but
when you say something that has like any
little bit of facetiousness in it people
get their britches in a twist and they'd
completely lose all sense of humor so
whatever I don't know what that has to
do with this but 150 billion that health
control bill and all of that and I am
totally with you that this country loves
to just play gotcha right you said a
word that pushed our button and the
hamsters hit the pedal and you know it's
it's you know everyone always has to go
away or apologize I mean this is one
that I heard you were defending Charlie
Sheen yeah and like him that's really
weird you're weird is that weird it's
like it makes you just want to be wrong
about everything
[Music]
[Applause]
what is the conservative like living
with [ __ ] the like whoredom and I'm
not defending the drug really I think
it's kind of sad when you look at it
because I think that he's something that
obviously not click what do you like the
fact that he went Falls to the wall and
says what he thinks and embraces
exceptionalism and was like yeah rock
star from Mars he's not a rock let me
tell you why it's not a rock star one
he's on a lousy sitcom okay that's I
made that point last week it's a lame
sitcom you're not a rock star from Mars
when you're on CBS okay - you guys great
you guys can talk about your
professional you know rock stars a the
girls they have her cuter you don't have
to pay them and you don't have to brag
about them I just like that he's being
honest with what he thinks and he
doesn't Qaddafi's honest
Hitler was on you know I mean honest if
you're honest about something stupid
that doesn't make it a great birth -
honey did I say I applauded you did you
said you liked him for his balls I like
yeah I like that he and he's like you
know what I turn tin cans to gold I
bring millions of dollars into this into
this network I you know make all this
money it's he's one of the highest let's
move on
why does everyone talk about the deficit
like it's the most important thing
happening well it's pretty important
yeah because very important yeah when
they quit buying our bonds yeah we just
rates go up people won't be able to get
credit in the economy crap yeah I heard
Erskine Bowles and Alan Simpson this
week saying we've got two years we've
got two years before it's China now I
think for that you don't know it's a
market so it's funny the markets react
but say they've reacted to Greece had
gone Portugal it
and our situation is not much different
than some of these countries in trouble
and worse it's getting worse as the baby
boomers retire we go into these
entitlement programs we got to have a
serious conversation about but what gets
me I try to race in the show earlier I
work for the president of balanced
budget I have a copy of it I work with
him I also net we can go together go go
get your old copy out of the 1999 budget
open it up and it says we are building
surpluses so vast that deep into the
future 2009 will have zero national debt
hey I handed that off to Karl Rove when
george w bush became president and they
were reversed it so deeply with this tax
cuts for the rich two wars on the
national credit card and giveaways to
corporations like oil companies and
pharmaceutical firms that's what did it
they didn't spend much money on
headstart actually prescription was even
worse but in addition to that the
economy crashed when he took office we
were going into a recession at the end
of the administration
if you repealed the Bush tax cuts alone
alone it would solve as much of the debt
problem as the entire bowles-simpson
Commission which is a very painful very
serious we may have to do some of those
things but that's one the
responsibilities of taxpaying citizens
to shore up politicians who keep
spending money that doesn't that isn't
their big taxes with text we tax it 15%
of our GDP right now 15 under country
tax that's not - that george w bush ran
up i don't understand why all of a
sudden you think it's like our money but
it's not our debt it's our country now I
also have a little more sympathy for
taxpaying citizens if they had a clue
what was going on with their taxes but
they don't well forty six percent of
households pay no federal income tax
right income tax they pay excise taxes
they pay payroll taxes for jails Maine
what's their completely schizophrenic
this when you ask them the general
question should we solve the deficit
absolutely yeah should we stop spending
yes what should we cut nothing right
they don't want to which they think is
like half the budget which is the sprig
of parsley on the plate that's what they
want to cut they don't want to take
anything away from the mass but
the fried chicken or the macaroni
someone will address it either right but
can you blame them because they're not
getting pressure from the people your
precious taxpayers are idiots that's the
problem I know we are we are I think we
are theoretical conservatives and
operational liberals so you say cut the
spending goes yeah yeah yeah right
nobody at a tea party rally ever held up
and burn their Medicare card right right
nobody ever said it's socialized
medicine care yeah I think al one key
party groups you go through it I really
have a bull's-eye on the entitlements I
think they understand the situation the
worst thing is built how do we spend our
money we talked about this before it's
on retirees it's not investments in the
future right it's not the way to win in
the global economy but they you know
they want the Swedish welfare state on
the Arizona tax base that's right that's
just never gonna happen thank you very
much panel Thank You audience pleasure
[Applause]